es que por más de 8 años ha salido a la
luz pública la relación del presidente
ruso vladimir putin el kremlin con
varios partidos de extrema derecha en
europa incluso en febrero de este año la
eurocámara presentó un informe donde
acusa a partidos a partidarios de estos
partidos europeos al servicio de
vladimir putin el informe sobre las
interferencias extranjeras y
desinformación fue realizado por un
comité experto que se tardó 18 meses de
trabajo donde se realizaron al menos 50
audiencias en las que fueron
entrevistados más de 130 expertos el
documento también alertó de la amenaza
que representan los regímenes
autocráticos extranjeros en particular
rusia y china además se ponen como
ejemplo los acuerdos de cooperación
firmados por partidos como el austriaco
o el pp o el francés agrupación nacional
o la liga en italia con la reducción
medida de vladimir putin así también
como los estrechos contactos con el
alemán a efe y el hobbit de hungría o
también el partido break sí que mantiene
la relación con el kremlin pues todo
esto vamos a conversar con josé
sanmartín en profesor titular de ciencia
política de la universidad de alicante
profesor gracias por acompañarnos en
directo américa de france 24 porque es
todos los vínculos de putin con la
extrema derecha de europa
buenas tardes muy amables en primer
lugar lo que hay que tener en cuenta es
que no es solo putin ha sido un
conglomerado un hinterland de
militarismo intereses económicos
etcétera etcétera los que han coadyuvado
a que en rusia haya tratado ese fenómeno
pero eso que ha ocurrido en rusia puede
ocurrir en cualquier otro país en
cualquier otro momento histórico y
volver a ocurrir lamentablemente si no
se adoptan medidas democráticas y de
salubridad pública que son
indispensables estas medidas
democráticas pueden ser como estas
sanciones este documento que presentó la
eurocámara
el informe de la eurocámara es un
elemento fundamentalmente positivo y ha
sido muy constructivo es un trabajo muy
elaborado muy argumentado muy solvente y
de altísima calidad pero es una medida
de prospectiva a posteriori si se va a
llamar de esa manera y tenemos que
evitar que esto vuelva a ocurrir como a
través de evidentemente desarrollo
democrático nuestros países
fiscalización control y evitación de que
las ideas políticas puedan ser a dos
ideas políticas ultranacionalistas anti
democráticas porque uno puede defender
cualquier credo político siempre que
tiene que estar respetando el derecho de
los otros países y por supuesto la
democracia no se conviertan en un veneno
tóxico que acabe con desarrollando pues
un virus patógeno que se llama
imperialismo y expansionismo desaforado
es lo que busca putting y el kremlin con
estos vínculos con estos partidos
europeos
sí y no vamos a ver el creen adoptado en
los últimos 15 años sobre todo porque
putin empezó como un reformador y fue
muy bien acogido por parte de occidente
en cuanto que significaba el fin de la
decadencia representada por por ilia
yashin y el desastre que quería rusia
bueno
no reflejaba para todo el mundo que no
voy a entrar en detalles porque es
demasiado desagradable y putin los
primeros años tuvo apoyo y apoyo muy
notable ese encuentro que estableció el
orden y de alguna manera una democracia
vigilada pero una democracia al fin y al
cabo lo que ha ocurrido en los últimos
años ha sido una deriva que no tiene
parangón y esa deriva en parte la
responsabilidad que tiene muchos
intelectuales y también no pocos hombres
de negocios etcétera dentro y fuera de
rusia voy a explicarlo es muy claro lo
que significa esto la reivindicación de
putin sobre la unión soviética es por el
imperialismo no por el comunismo útil lo
sabemos es un ultranacionalista de un
perfil ideológico muy concreto pero es
extremadamente transversal él se
aprovecha de muy diferentes corrientes y
las usa a su favor el objetivo
fundamental es diseminar en occidente
sobre todo en los países miembros de la
otan y los países no miembros de la otan
pero muy próximos a la idea occidental
si lo queremos llamar de esa manera y el
ultranacionalismo propio en cada país al
objeto de debilitar la alianza atlántica
y todo lo que signifique la identidad
occidental es fomentar un patrioterismo
burdo y exagerado en el cual todo está
basado en la autoconfianza nacional y
por supuesto en detrimento de la
confianza de los aliados profesor
entonces con estas acciones putting se
perturba realmente a la alianza
atlántica la otan
y estamos focalizando mucho en putting
pero es que aunque putting deje el poder
el problema va a persistir no sólo en
rusia sino en varios países más donde
esa ideología anti occidental y
antidemocrática esta semilla da en
elementos fundamentales de su economía
de su pensamiento no olvidemos por
ejemplo un fundamento de la geopolítica
un libro de alexander dosing de la en
1997 ese es el manual que está
siguiéndose ahora en la operación entre
comillas o sea en la guerra blindada
contra ucrania en ese ahora y en otras
porque el elenco de obras de literatura
en esa materia es enorme pues hay muchos
países del mundo afectados y se explican
metodologías claro en esa bibliografía
como digo que es pavorosa mente
siniestra de cómo infiltrarse en un país
como fomentar el ultranacionalismo que
debilite las alianzas militares de esos
países para protegerse mutuamente de
esta manera se deja en la indefensión a
esos países porque ya de forma
individual
el poder x el que fuere se nos puede
comer no puede demorar no voy a entrar
en muchos detalles pero por ejemplo
colombia es un país que podría ser
afectado por ese tipo de sinergia entre
otros muchos países de américa del sur y
burundi esa visión geopolítica ya digo
es expansionista imperialista y
claramente criminal como quedan entonces
parados estos líderes políticos que
salieron digamos en estas en esta
información y de la eurocámara además
como le podría afectar por ejemplo a
estos líderes políticos también en estas
elecciones francesas que vienen el
próximo 10 de abril en primera vuelta
eso lo decidirá el polo francés pero es
evidente que no es una noticia positiva
para ellos en tanto que tomarse ahora o
aparecer ahora con una foto con según
qué personajes no es lo más popular ni
lo que lo que va a conseguir llevarte en
final al cenit de la fama mundial es
evidente que eso es un lastre todos
están soltando lastre pero los hechos
son los hechos y hay que tener en cuenta
que al final si uno tiene una visión
democrática y occidental de lo que deben
ser las relaciones internacionales que
se basan en la paz y el intercambio
productivo pues esas esos candidatos van
a quedar afectados por una parte de su
electorado seguramente no por otra lo
importante es que acaba un pedagogía y
que se expliquen realmente qué
significan ese tipo de nuevas ideologías
populistas y ultranacionalistas que lo
que esconden es un odio visceral a la
democracia de cualquier fenómeno de
representación digna para la persona
pues profesor muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 conversando
sobre este tema la verdad ha sido un
placer
muy amables un honor